welcome to the panel on future
directions and applications and
communication networks some of you may
know my father-in-law he's he was a
longtime professor in EC Illinois and
when he found out that I was going to
John Waldron retirement he said he's a
kid why is he retiring I was trying to
think when I met John I think it was at
a communication networking conference in
the early to mid 90s I think it was
around 1994 and I was trying to look up
on the internet it was a time when he
John gave a plenary at this conference
in Boca Raton which they used to hold
around the time and it was so long ago
that there's no information about it on
the internet so even though it's been
only 25 years it doesn't seem like that
long but this was predates the internet
so I heard John talk for the first time
there and before that my idea of a talk
was I thought the whole idea of giving a
talk was to confuse the audience there
was a brilliant person getting up and
giving a talk that was outstanding in
depth but also understandable to
everybody and so that was an inspiration
to me
so you've been an inspiration to me John
in many ways not just giving talks by
your work John has always been at the
cutting edge of research I remember when
I was in Bell Labs was a lot of work on
trying to understand what are the
benefits of moving from a circuit switch
to a packet-switched Network and a lot
of people there were reading John's work
along with those of co-authors here on
large deviations and later when I
started working on Internet congestion
control Joe introduced this notion of
alpha fairness and and later on again in
the area of wireless networking you know
I think Kumar already mentioned that
introduces IDF CSMA combined with queue
length information so John has always
been a leader and telling everybody else
what one should work on and so today's
panel yes I supposed to be future
direction so maybe one way to interpret
it would be to try to figure out what
John will be working on for the next
so we have put together three wonderful
researchers in our area so Muhammad
Ali's arrived Balaji Prabhakar and
promote this or not
so each of them will give about a
three-minute introduction to what they
are working on right now or what they
think are great future directions and
networking and then I hope to involve
the audience and hope it'll be an
interactive session trying to figure out
what are some interesting trends in this
area so I invite Mohammed to first give
his three minute pitch okay thank you
yes I will first John congratulations
it's really an honor to be here in 2013
when I was just going on the job market
I remember John invited me to give a
talk in his group and he gave me a ton
of very useful advice I'm very grateful
for that
so what I wanted to talk about very
briefly is actually related to the
discussion we're having at the end of
andreas presentation and that's that you
know in designing network systems we
often face this tension between
optimality and universality and I think
machine learning has a role to play in
kind of breaking this tension and it's
one of the sort of the big you know
areas and promises of machine learning
and networking so that's what this
picture is supposed to show here you
know in this box and the xs/s you and
the x-axis you have universality of you
know environments that are either very
heterogeneous or environments are
homogenous and the y-axis you have
performance and if you look at sort of
classical approaches to network control
they're really about these two corners
of this box you know if you look at
Internet protocols like the TCP transfer
protocol they're really achievements in
designing so for for very universal
conditions
you know TCP works in incredibly wide
range of wide range of networks it's not
really optimal in any of them and
there's a lot of research on kind of
specializing TCP for different types of
networks it's kind of classical
approaches are also have been very
fruitful in environments that are
homogenous you know we have very good
models for them and for example in
datacenter networking and there's some
transport over the last decade we've
seen a lot of
work on designing a very specialized
protocols that perform extremely well
what's missing from this picture is this
remaining corner of the picture and I
think this is where machine learning has
a role to play in in the future it's
really about you know can we use
data-driven techniques in machine
learning to augment Network protocols so
that we can design that works I can
adapt to very heterogeneous conditions
without sacrificing optimality and so my
group you know recently been working on
a number of systems that use machine
learning particularly reinforcement
learning techniques in the contents of
never control and we try to learn that
protocols that are essentially you know
learned through experience and this one
give you one example of that and that
we've recently been working on is a
scheduler for cluster computing systems
so there's a system that's designed sort
of for a very general case in a lot of
systems in in did a lot of data
processing systems represent jobs as you
know DAGs of stages so you have you know
these jobs that come in TOR don't think
of a system like spark there's
processing stages that's what these
nodes are and you have dependencies they
do defenses between stages so for
example node cannot start until all of
its dependencies are met and these kind
of systems give rise to very complicated
scheduling problems so it's a kind of an
example of you know not empty hard but
empty really hard that Andrea was
talking about and we've been building
you know a system that can learn how to
solve these problems essentially using
reinforcement learning and through
experience so just as an example of you
know what this you know looks like this
is sort of a spark visualization of
spark writing ten different jobs these
red lines are the completion events of
the jobs this is before we've trained
our system and as you train the system
it learns better and better scheduling
policies and eventually learns policies
that actually we don't really know how
to beat I mean it's about 2x faster than
the best human example problem that we
don't have really sort of optimal
algorithms for I always say I'm gonna
keep it a very high level I won't have
time to go any details on this but I
have talked to you more about it
so I I'll I'll stop there looking
forward to this guy
[Music]
order by saying Jean you first time we
met I was a postdoc here about the one
quarter between finishing up PhD at UCLA
and then getting to go to UK for a
postdoc and we are nick bamboos I'm your
grandson the great-grandson so the tree
in this case is Luke routed approving of
Araya is like very fertile a lot of a
lot of people here so proteins like the
Chinese con of networking they're
talking with searches you're like coming
out of the Karine genetic pool okay so
they were happy to just share a few
things like she learned from Praveen and
wrong long ago because I was a late
entrant internetworking PhD since I was
more a control theory guy working
Balakrishnan than Nick came to UCLA and
I began to work with him so you know we
all know this I'm gonna be brief about
there was telephony and circuit
switching and packet switching showed
out it had this motivation of like you
must be connected regardless of the
circumstances you must make sure
connection or communication as possible
very early days there were these two
branches of communication and
computation you know that was you know
ARPANET etc and the side was of the
hippie
there were DARPA projects and NSF
projects down this path computation path
the multik system or MIT and so on one
side fried the other side sort of
petered out okay a supercomputing was
still the big thing on that side and the
reason I think was simply is best at for
design it was just when all you have to
do is make sure things are connected you
don't really care you're on the you're
on the universality side in order to be
carrying on with the optimality and so
it was able to scale and most
importantly it got always commodity
hardware going whether it's the Cisco
junipers of the world or the several
guys like Dell and so on the other side
computing side okay and so fast for the
2000
so the high-performance side just you
know kind of petered out it was
difficult to scale make him cheap so
this is sort of what it looks like
you know decisively Ethernet an Internet
of one out mobile networks got added and
we slowly started moving away from
communication networks to computing so
the you know it's you know arguable that
there was nothing here to begin with now
there's a lot of it that's all cloud
computing isn't here for example and but
the communication you know
infrastructure used is still that okay
and so people have wanted to have you
know when you move from data here you
can asking questions the wizened when I
took my network more programmable like
my computer and they let people to Nick
and harvest to define programmable T I
think that's another where I have water
on tree offspring okay the other Nick so
cell programming networks is a quest for
programs that's what we're working on so
this is nice to know that it
programmable but what are the programs
okay so we want to make network sense
and martyr themselves and control and
program themselves so if we think of it
as a combination of engineering and
design the way you can think of it is so
it's not an accident you sort of trying
to come up with the name for a project
and then you look around self-driving is
the cool new prefix so you just grab
onto it you use it word however you want
it always work self-driving toothbrushes
for example or anything some driving
shoes whatever you want so it's it's a
useful prefix is electoral in the 90s
plain old car and add sense and control
to it you'll get a self-driving car
that's not goal this transformation
costs about $20,000 dollars that's about
30% of the cost of the car in this case
roughly you could also consider doing
that to data centers where you have data
centers processing some workload and has
support some apps if you have sense and
control to it you make it self
programming network I just need to tell
you about where we're doing sales in
control briefly and we're all we're
doing it all
the Knicks okay so skipping ahead what
does that mean to sense and control of
the Knicks so we're not touching the
switches we're not touching the server's
okay so you know you sort of now in the
world of tomography which works in the
case of data centers because you're
looking at transmit and receive
timestamps of packets and then piecing
together what happened inside the
network and since you're taking
timestamps at different servers critical
it's the use of clocks you have to
synchronize the clocks okay so this is
sort of the motivation and there's a
whole bunch of things to say about is
this is what we're working on is it a
wave at the moment it certainly feels
like a ripple it could be a wave who
knows but the thing we found immediately
is that it's very interesting so who
cares about time financial industry does
there are different parts of the
financial industry we found that need it
I'm the way you needed to think of a
Nasdaq like exchange this is from the
Deutsche börse so guys it's very
critical the world the world fairness
applies in this universe what it means
is that if I submit a bid to the
exchange then my bid cannot be overtaken
by your bed if your bid came after my
bid even though they came with different
gateways so it turns out with
synchronize clocks you can actually
manage to re-sequence
just before execution and also on the
outbound order book delivery side so
that nobody gets an advantage of seeing
what the prices look like you can also
do it on the outbound side so the last
thing I want to say is this has been
trialed and there was this sort of front
page story in the New York Times about
it and it was really about if you
whittling at you know this clock sink
and why it's interesting for the
financial industry so Jon's heard me say
this has described it to him earlier but
hopefully this industry where high
performance networks matters and you're
still already in the world of commodity
networks and you know unstructured cloud
like environments because these trans
guys take great pains to make the
latency is really small there's some
possibility here that the
self-programming type work we're doing
could be relevant but to me represents
an interesting opportunity
so thank you
yeah
[Music]
thank you for coming to this session and
thank you for inviting me
organizers most of all happy medium I
met John and all 96 around this time 22
years ago towards on my preliminary and
community of Berkeley clearly I'm from
the same tree changing times in a strong
Marko theorem and I also know the
question I get asked in praveen asked my
committee members then since then I've
been interacting which now over the
years occurs in many many roles is taken
me to the music performances on
Wednesday afternoons great fun thank you
it's really been a privilege knowing you
and I'm very happy to be in this panel
I'm working on blockchains in the last
couple of years I've had a few students
graduate we've worked on a variety of
aspects of blockchain some of them may
be getting open sourced into Bitcoin
core we've been working on box ends and
I think this is my Bible it's really
just exactly for this society in this
community in this room it's easy systems
in the world so that's like Part III we
just want to say there are three things
here I don't need to define these things
here for this audience that's good but
the other part of the equation is what
our block chains and there's plenty of
bubble it's bit ironical that I have
explained beyond about who I was I saw
this last year on highway 85 bumper
sticker saying
just one more bubble before I die a
startup but but I do want to think and I
think blockchains really or the core of
some force beyond the bubble and maybe
temporary McGowan comfort it's something
that advances the genetic and
evolutionary advantage of humans as a
race only didn't you know well no but
all these words well you take advantage
of humans and species have been that you
can cooperate a be flexibly see in large
numbers and historical mods this notion
of tasks and even don't trust in a
flexible large number way scalable way
and historical notes of trust used to be
driver communication he looked like me
we have the same can same facial
expressions and same language so we have
trust and then that evolved into
institutional cooperation in science and
probably that of course is that power is
at the top and the force comes and not
change really are along this line of
trust it's a way of getting distributed
trust and anything that pushes such a
basic evolutionary advantage of humans
we learn go ahead not just be above all
and the fact that you can do this
cooperation in a distributed way it was
already demonstrated by big fun for ten
years right exactly ten years over at
the peak of the financial bubble bobbler
lion crash just about the crash time is
when came out the fact that you can do
it sensibly was done by etherium four
years ago bar that you notion of smart
contracts so it's not just currency but
it's a programmable currency you can do
it flexible the biggest challenge that
required block chain saw is the third
part can do it as large diverse in other
words scalability take it to man one
child in fact and that's what I've been
working on I think much of the community
bob chains one soul card there isn't
that much of an overlap with the
academics so the course at Berkeley
one block came to start but two
undergraduates in late in the evening
that's for la spring so it's not haven't
had much self yet work in academic
community but I think it's we should
change and part of this panel is I'm
evangelizing a bit for that and today I
want the evangelize is by saying that
it's really at the core of it especially
when you want to scale is a mixture of
networking and incentives which if I
take these two titles and variants of
where it's probably 50% overlap with
many people CB s-- is the core of what
we do two types of the equality problems
one is what would say on chain
networking so this is a peer-to-peer
network where your basic primitive is
broadcast I won't tell everybody
something something usually refers to a
transaction I'd name if it's a
cryptocurrency application and because
it's distribute that we've different
people here in different times and the
ordering is off and this notion of a
synchrony if you wish and difference in
timestamps admits when it was done in
when it was received and different
people have different views the
blockchain world has a name for it they
call it for King and the best word of
address for K is sort of we could do it
one way to do it is what traditional
blockchain methods have done Bitcoin
then they try to have a specific way of
breaking the fourth choice rows so if
you have a fourth then you follow the
main longest chain so that provides some
way of cutting down this form but it
reduces throughput because they're all
the other things are dead and they will
come back get renewed and they're often
box the other ways for synchrony and
this is another different approach you
know we might know about al-quran from
the mighty Stella's from Stanford and
but they increase latency and things are
so wrong but the heart of it is really
can perhaps do something the network
toilet no no both of these an algorithm
level data higher level ideas to reduce
quality but perhaps one can try
something at the network level and
that's something we've been trying so
for example here are three different
people they have a view of the
blockchain and they're on there all are
the same and there's a global view page
no none of them have and now if somebody
wants to propose a new block which is a
group of transactions then perhaps the
proposer and nobody knows where it
should fail how it fits in but but it
contradicts how these guys looked at and
one possibility is that just before
proposing this a broadcast look at that
maybe you should pull a few people get
their view local views and update your
view and from there build on top of it
so if this sounds like there is some
power of the choices going on here and
it's actually text and so one can prove
theorems about it except this time
they're not joining the shortest queue
by pulling the join the longest and
asymptotics are all about how large the
largest one is because it's not
knowledge since this information ballots
saying at you the way you do it is by
having as few walls in any of the pins
except one and yeah and then there's
something specific to blockchain send
to' and something actively being worked
on by many block kids got proof of state
that's well that's the kind of
challenges that come on all chain
networking so I want to take up an
account
this is collaboration where Julia
pantyhose known to many people here
she's only working full-time at our
startup and Jem tau who's a professor
here and my colleague say we'll go from
there now this one type of networking
another type of networking is what one
call off chain and the idea is that
instead of having a people
work on change even if you're going to
buy a $5 sorry we put a $5 yeah
it's tilting of the fight over lunch
aims to get to 98 but it's $1 today but
and we're that you already have made
some pot it's like a gift card
it's of merchants that you already have
you already have put in some less crowd
money and maybe when you go visit it
it's a much easier way of brass because
you already have it but if it's the same
merchants that's good but you don't have
with every possible merchants have too
much money to go and escrow a great time
for something that you don't use
so perhaps you want to rolls through
other people to get to the merchants if
you've not done so these are not off
chain networks so every time you want to
make a transaction you use these escrows
to do it and the key challenges you want
to do there is now things in a way that
it doesn't deplete balances along the
way and perhaps is the least amount of
s-curve and these are not cable channels
within the notion of and this is
conserved for a wide way of slowly
scaling the blockchain instead of doing
everything consensus and for each
transaction something should be taken
off and yeah so the idea is that you
already have and then you can just once
you have once they've already committed
something on the clock then the cycle
give the card between these to me I know
I can have a network of these people
then they can go back and forth and this
Heights reflect the what the imbalances
how much I have paid on my direction
compared to the other notice it as a
conservation and you want to make this
balance and everything else you have to
find a way through this path through the
balance there's a balance should be
large enough along the way and the way
ropings is done is through source
routing and trying to find paths from
the source and you find a series like
there's the words and then you find a
circuit in other words to go to it but
really that's old-school networking for
a networking person this is kind of
naive produce circuit switching sorts of
things and we have packet switching
the whole variety of work being sent to
everyone distributed routing and
transport and one should exploit really
decades of work of bringing tried and
tested through networking principles to
another area this is joint you build
something called spider so maybe yeah so
it's it's a packet switch Network which
is balance of air and this joint work
with the Julia again and the Muhammad
Ali's a devil's here so really very few
irreverent many of these people now as
people of collaborators at various
levels some working full-time on leave
from the collaborators so are there any
questions or comments so if you I'll
start off by asking a Balaji for example
so so for all three of you I guess what
so what is some what are some
fundamental differences between how the
internet works versus data centers I
mean data centers are you know also have
lots and lots of computers maybe not as
many as the internet but in the early
days of the internet property there were
just as many computers so what are some
fundamental differences between data
centers and and the internet and and
also in in how does it how does it
affect the way you do research
I think you will think of doing
computation or will the internet
necessarily okay but you wouldn't when
Jess enters you is primarily for
computation but it is supporting of
course a lot of entertainment I learn on
Netflix Amazon Prime all these guys but
I think the biggest difference is that I
think that that is an unexpected and
really a massive success I think that
success had to do lot with the work
mostly early on at Google like BigTable
bigquery everything became distributed
computation databases a border called
pump subsystem publish/subscribe so I
think this is like a huge revolution
I think the system's side of CS took
over and ingrates that whole disturb
your computation facilities available in
the cloud I think that's the big
difference
communication what is computation and
then every kind of aspect of
computations are storage
yeah I think that's I think that's
that's spot-on you know the biggest
difference is in the kinds of
applications that people run in data
centers and you know these distributed
computations and the infrastructure
itself is different you know the
networks are high speed low latency the
switches are kind of have different
constraints but one of the interesting
things I say that I think you know it
seems like it's going to happen is it's
true that so far we haven't really
thought of doing computation over the
internet but it's likely that we will
have to think more about systems like
that for a variety of reasons I mean
there's just the amount of data that's
being generated there's 20 million
cameras I heard in Beijing in London for
every seven people there's one camera
soon every car is going to have a camera
and we're gonna want to do inference on
all of these you know these these like
video streams there's no way we're going
to actually centralize all that data and
do whatever comes we want in data
centers and so I think one of the
interesting challenges is can we think
of these computational platforms that
are not so centralizing and actually
operate over the internet and we think
about you know how do you balance
communication and computation and things
like that it can't be the mobile
computing cars are all computing that's
right and it was a kind of an area that
you know people thought about you know
peer-to-peer was the scible citizen kind
of went away with data centers but in
some sense because of the volume data
that's being generated you know at the
edge of you know our networks and and
because of other reasons you know
because a lot of places you have
restrictions on whether you connect you
can take data you know from one country
and move it to a different country so
there's a lot of reasons like people
want their data to stay local and that's
gonna force I think more forces to think
more about these systems that actually
do computational attention
I have a question which has to do with
tons of data and trust consultation and
my question is what would it take so
that I can trust the news that I receive
many many variations of the same item I
don't even know what it means to trust
that particular piece that I hear or see
or read how would you among all the
bubbles in those cryptocurrencies phase
one is for daughter and they're trying
to essentially trying to grow these
prediction markets which will where you
put money and it will be certain ESCO
and if your partner or if you are not
getting toward anyone when you have to
say your thing
then your money gets deducted for it so
it's like you put your money where your
mouth is and it's held in escrow until
you throw right and I think one thing is
to do within mainstream markets and try
to sort of decipher what is take news
what is in art the other perhaps is to
have all in the mind that is what is
fake is not be so fake for the person
who's creating it and if enough people
put their money where into an escrow and
say a certain view then I'm not
definitely being tested out today within
the blockchain infrastructure
so the Koch brothers would have partly
not Koch brothers could influence what
is fake Koch brother I can inject tons
of fake stuff my question is as a
receiver of this how do I
is there any way in the socially or
somehow or the other so one thing that's
happened is proof of work is it is not
you know people have done this for spam
suppress pan you know ever send emails
unless you do some work and the work is
usually something you know your blow
some computer cycles if you put that
burden on news generation that could
stem a little bit whether it's still
gonna be quality that's not obvious the
Wikipedia seems to work pretty well you
know it is information it's on news the
difference there's less opinion right
and so I think that's even the world of
news there are different viewpoints
right there there's on the right and
this or left and right sort of outlets
you want classically I think most change
is just speed at which things are
happening and there's no seemingly easy
way of standing it right now but I think
if you go to a model way socially
curated like Wikipedia style well then
it comes to who's curating it it's not
you know this is more fundamental I
think it's more the same incident can
review two different ways there's not
much anybody no valid in a way so I
don't have a Buddhist better answer than
that
my question is kind of stepping back so
I think promotes presentation
this is networking this is plastic
assistance your perspective right so I
think the question is if you had twos
right now from today is pointed through
the same what is network like
intellectually today not historical
think could you say is there something
that can be static in a fresher deal
this is what you think is what you said
all fall to you what do you think of
today what is that electric should there
should there be never yeah no there's no
question about - these are driver one or
wanting to see it it's not it's not
invisible it's very highly visible I
think the definition is is less
communication exclusively much more
computation oriented it's seriously
dominant it's the amount of money that
some of the computation guys are making
compared the communication guys is it
scary
it used to be when you know when Cisco
the packet switching taking over from
circuit switching in a way I'm drawing
whatever new share not everything
it's similarly happening now computation
is taking over from communication if you
like Amazon's like supposed to give
hundred billion dollars in just revenues
from its cloud side and they're all
running towards that you know it's the
fastest-growing parts of all these
companies I think that's happening and
that is you know networking but your
point is is it there it's there but what
is it intellect
what is it intellect I think it's it's
less about you know just point to point
or anyone it's more about this sort of
what he was talking about this dag that
there's a common purpose for many nodes
there's some application some job and
how can several nodes get together to do
that
one thing that is the difference I'd say
between when I was a student to now we
never asked that question really wasn't
part of the ethos this fear systems
existed but didn't really become like
what networks were supposed to be
serving all of the computation has
changed that I think it's quite exciting
that many things that was going on there
with me you want accent yeah I mean I
think yeah I don't know if I have a lot
to add I mean I think that it is really
about you know the shift that has
happened from communication to thinking
more about what we're trying to do with
this you know what is the goal the goal
of the application that's because I
think that certainly it's something
that's kind of very central in thinking
about how we operate data centers and
how we design protocols for those
centers and I think it's gonna it's
going to expand to to the rest you know
to wide-area to all other networks as
well
one thing I wanted to say is that even
though that working and directly flicks
into something like block chains but
their information allowed for example
have this thing for the information
collision channel and for packet
positions even Aloha and I have a
protocol called Mahalo the second most
popular word in Hawaiian informational
level and technical stakes and you can
you say a little bit more about that
what would it be my information
collision yeah I think different people
have different views of the block chains
it's a tree right and you would like to
all of them to agree on some things and
having this agreement is the fact that
there is forking which is inherently
caused by the distributed aspect of the
networking problem causes information
collision and you would like to come up
with protocols that reduce it that one
example of a showing was and you may
want to wait I have this brief before
you speak generally a good thing and
it's also good in these networks I think
they come back it's not directly a
packet collision but some information
pollution so it helps the algorithm mix
with the networking more as what process
is called yeah
we talk about privacy in any way of
using some blockchain or some way so
that puts ups but in the system so that
it just kills all my keys
some ways to be of killing the
distributed system with respect to my
information we just raising your at will
so I have control over my information
but my information how this is all over
the place and its aim is to be that
system like is there some way of
reversing it this has come up in two
ways that I know one way is you know the
you know the way symptomatic seem starts
this question is how can I learn my
information so I can make money out of
it okay which hopefully is close to how
can I destroy that there's like you know
your core you are portion of the
shopping data that amazon has source
already else and so you need to be
reimbursed for your thing that Amazon
makes out of you for example because you
spawn some collaborative filtering I see
that give the user bit more control of
their information deciding what they
want to provide I know does it exist a
solution not yet we've all spoken about
it the the other one is mostly on social
networks and is this sort of weird way
in which things seem to like trickle out
about oneself just by the mere fact that
one is just reading stuff for you know
liking stuff for what they're looking at
and or even what you're searching for on
the web you know things like this that
is us you know is really the GDP are the
European Union's by Fiat at the moment
is the way it's going I'm sure you had
to go back and every every site you're
accessing I was asking you to carefully
look at the privacy policy and
prove told it'll be written maybe that's
the way in the short term I'd be good
good good thing maybe you want some you
know program to accompany your data
there there are companies I think
working on this kind of a thing of like
a social network that's sort of backed
by blockchain and supposed to make let
you be in control of your data I mean I
haven't sort of looked too deeply into
like what is like how do they do it and
what's the underlying technologies but
it is built on top of you know these
kind of smart contract
you know technologies it is really a
program that you get to see in a company
your data
the question cooler is that you want to
do it retroactivity right that means
you've already but afterwards you want
to go and erase that absolutely I
thought about this I thought actively
about doing it while you're producing
data that's dandelion and so forth but
but really the whole point is it's that
is out there in public and once it's the
hell it's there what you're talking
about this optimality universality so
two questions maybe one is easier
transact and have you looked at the
cases whether you can recover some of
the solutions we know in the homogeneous
space and then and how good it does or
how long it takes and then also in the
university ality give me more specific
because I can think of universality in
terms of allowing a lot of the interface
and I would require really opening up
the you know the hardware side to be
able to provide that kind of control
versus universality in terms of the
protocol structure so do you have
anything yes so I mean in terms of
seeing whether learning algorithms can
recover sort of things that we know I've
done things like that in my work where
for example for scheduling problems show
that you know this learning algorithm
will learn like policies like SRPT
you know learn
I think promote is in a different
context you know for communication has
worked on things where you know he shows
that a learning like an RNN can learn to
decode turbo codes
learn the Viterbi algorithm you know in
some sense so I think there's there's
been a lot of work like that where we
don't think people have done things like
that I remember that when he was talking
about it
it required like really curating a
particular planet day that the most
informative examples to make sure that
the data was not enough by itself to
actually lead it to the right way in a
room any code word there exactly so was
there a similar thing that you know so
in yeah so in every one of these things
it's one of things that kind of in the
work that you know we've done we've
learned is you know you can't kind of
treat the algorithm as a black box and
just hope that you know you can like
give it all the input data
you know ransom great reinforcement
yogam and they will like it will just
like magically work I mean it's so
you're reinforced morning at its core is
pretty dumb right it's like you know run
a lot of experiments observe what
happens and then follow a gradient so to
get effective algorithms you actually do
have to think a lot about what's the
right representation of that problem
you know an example of this actually
some some work that we've recently been
doing bit of a brat we were actually
just as curiosity we're wondering you
know can you recover sort of switch
scheduling you know problems and so you
actually succeeded you know we can like
have a learning algorithm that does max
weight matching you know as good as the
best max of watching sort of variance
that we know on so scheduling problems
but we have to think a lot about how do
we condense the representation to get
together
so for sure a lot of sort of
domain-specific and sites go into every
one of these but what's nice is you know
once you kind of have these nice
representations you get very flexible
system so if you change something about
your metrics change something about the
nature of your system you don't have to
like rethink your algorithms from
scratch you'll discover these algorithms
as you go okay I know I don't have time
to talk about Java but I just want to
say that his ramification went all the
way to Africa and he was even there
and there's my appreciated my question
goes to promote Africa is somewhere
where trust to the US Edition is really
an issue
and now blockchain is really raising a
lot of hope that it can replace many but
the problem we have there is
infrastructure is not there in term of
computation but also communication links
are going up and down so if the network
that we talked about think that you do
blockchain in a resource environment
yeah actually that is exactly the title
of proposal that the advanced over here
is the parting me and the noise which is
understanding or distributed trusting
resource constrained environments yeah
in fact much of other network driven
ideas I started developing on chains
were driven by that kind of workshop
well that idea where you are inherently
the resource constrained environment
primarily on network server it's a
wireless
unless rahiewl better question so in the
last three or four decades it seems that
there's been very fast innovation on
various aspects of networks and
reporting technology except maybe the
last mile so in the last mile it seems
that we're still using technologies and
protocols that have been there for maybe
two or three decades so is that a
problem or is that could have become a
problem and if so then what kind of
innovation is could happen maybe Andrea
can answer this way so are we gonna
replace it so I don't completely agree
with that because fibre is certainly
advanced it is not faster yeah there's
economic sense and there's just
logisitics of bling fibre everywhere so
if the question is is Wireless going to
replace all the wired network for the
last mile you know if you there's been
waves of fixed wireless access pretty
much every decade and they've all failed
and you know when you look at what's
really the killer value proposition of
wireless its movement if you have a
fixed system then Wireless doesn't have
the same benefits as wired and so and
it's very fragile still I mean
unfortunately there's still the laws of
physics which don't necessarily come in
some of the networking things but you
know you can set up a link that's a 10
gigabit per second link fixed wireless
access and then it's something walks
through it or drive through it and then
your life falls apart so I'm a skeptic
about fixed wireless access because it's
failed every single time then it's come
into play and I think that we can do
better I think it would be cheaper and
more reliable to try to use wire
technology there but you know the
question raised is a more interesting
one related to this discussion which is
you know you think about more broadly
communications
networking drove right I mean a lot of
the success of Electrical Engineering
was in those two fields and now we're
starting to see both of those fields be
viewed kind of as some atoms out there
commodities there isn't so much
innovation left to do and everything is
moving their computer science and so I
mean is that true I think broadening
your question are there real break needs
to be had and I think there is an
Wireless that's about trying to push
that but are they breakthrough said
networking is EE can it have a
resurgence because to do all the stuff
you guys are talking about blockchain
and computational all of this we still
need the hardware and the infrastructure
to support it so that's a great question
I think I mean the question is where is
he and where where is yes and I think
it's probably the case that we've
defined what these things are and
sometimes we've defined it a little
narrowly as happens and it's clean when
it's narrower it's clear what we're
talking about like you know the
well-known communication diagrams in the
control system reference diagrams in the
first chapter of every book and that
sometimes can limit too much and I just
up to us too
you know of the state of mind sort of
comment you need the state of mind we
don't have to be box in there I think
there's another take I have on it I've
been trying to no I throw it out they
need some refinement but maybe it's
somewhat true
I think feels an engineering that have
lost touch with the consumer end up
being like a back office back and you
know things CSS maintain that touch
which is thrived mechanical engineering
was in danger of petering out and then
took the design school approach went
directly in front of the person the UI
or Stanford design school others to I
think the consumer frontier is just not
worth abandoning I think the mechanical
error Astros reinventing itself of drums
how cool is that actually right I think
the problem with us is us being now EE
it's not a problem it's an observation
now I don't never seem true I think that
consumer edge is just worth finding a
touch point to we had phones but then
we're operating systems that's what
makes those phones cool if you had
button phones is not that interesting
mostly complaining about it that you
were saying on your own Drive you know I
think that's probably where we need a
touch point some clear easily
identifiable and then we will try and
Costas who say in the morning that this
is not the sort of thing we like to do
because it feels too mercenary I don't
think that's right I've been iced not be
sure what the business school teaches
until I taught there and tell me what it
does it takes a decision making that's
all it does
manager is someone who doesn't know
anything except facts as at all to that
person and they have choices that'll
make a decision that's all they do all
know regain okay and the good good at it
it's like poker players this practice
select a good manager is really a good
of this and they don't have to be the
guys to generate the facts that that's
for engineers or build systems I think
that's okay I've said
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]